hello guys and girls raj here back with
another video
merry christmas and happy holidays uh so
a lot of you guys and girls are probably
off this coming week
and then from end of january and
february
hiring is gonna start on full force so
in this video
i am going to specifically talk about
step-by-step skills required
for these cloud jobs devops engineer
slash architect
solutions architect sysadmin or security
or governance engineers less architect
and software developer as always i have
given the timestamps in the video
and before we get started little bit
about me for those who are new to the
channel
my name is raj i'm a senior specialist
architect working
at aws and previously i was a
distinguished cloud architect
at verizon also developer and before
that i was a mainframer at jp morgan
chase
i'm also a published udemy and
pluralsight author and instructor
and my free time i enjoy playing some
video games i am going to categorize the
skills
in three different categories
one is must have so you should
have these skills if you are applying
for the role
second category is highly recommended it
is
going to make you very valuable and if
there are multiple candidates
with the same skills and if you have
this highly recommended skill
you will be given priority and number
three
is low return so this kind of skills
requires lots of hands-on and studying
but they have very low impact on
interviews and
generally you can learn this once you
get into the job
so the first role which is the most
popular role
is devops engineer slash architect
what this job encompasses is
you will have to automate different
processes
such as infrastructure like spinning up
services
you have to automate the software
release and software delivery
and you also have to automate
remediation in case something goes wrong
another responsibility is monitoring and
reporting from the pipeline
from the processes etc and the
superpower will be
this is a super versatile role and you
can branch out
to other roles if needed from this role
personally
i actually started in this role
so this role i really like this role so
let's look into the skill tree
i have given the preferred sequence
but you can change the order as you see
fit
so you should start with the
infrastructure as code
so if you are going for aws devops
architecture engineer
you should learn cloud formation and you
can pick your infrastructure as code for
gcp and azure
or you can learn terraform so you do not
need to learn
both cloud formation and terraform to
apply to these positions
so once you have the concept and you
know one
then you can pick up the other ones as
well
the next important thing is you need to
know git commands
as a devops architect you need to
trigger your pipeline anytime or
sometimes a code is merged
you need to know how to create branches
clone it
merge it how to do pull requests etc
then move into devops services
so you could learn either cloud specific
services
uh for example if you are going for aws
then you could learn code commit code
build code deploy and code pipeline
or you can learn jenkins or gitlab
again you do not need to learn all three
for applying to this job because
once you know one of this the other ones
will be very easy for you to learn
all right next is highly recommended
that you actually know how to deploy
devops pipelines
for a virtual machine like you are
deploying code in ec2
and also code in microservices
so it could be you're deploying an api
uh you with the backend code and the api
gateway
those if you can demonstrate that you
actually deployed some pipeline
and it could be in your personal account
that's fine
if you know the flow the design and the
actual hands-on
this will be golden next
if you can learn relevant technology
that is highly recommended
so you can mix and match depending on
your interest
so you should have a basic understanding
of
virtual machines such as ec2 for aws
container concepts and serverless like
lambda
api gateway again you can mix and match
because it will be impossible to uh
master all this in a month
and next is a cloud certification this
one you guys and girls probably know
note that this cloud certification is
only handy to get you in the interview
once you are in the interview you have
to demonstrate that you have
these must have skills so next
is the low return corner case devops
services
so i have seen a lot of times people
spend a lot of time on services like
elastic bin stock aws code star
the newly one aws proton
most of the organizations like use
the code pipeline jenkins git lab you do
not need to know these corner cases
and if you demonstrate that you know uh
the the cloud specific code pipeline
jenkins gitlab the interviewer will know
that you can pick up
this elastic bin stock and other corner
case devops services
uh similarly like no need to dive deep
into ansible
it is important that you know what is
ansible and how
you can integrate it with the dev of
services but you do not need to know
ansible chef puppet in detail
and this is based on the job requirement
that i
analyzed to make this video so most of
the devops jobs do not require you
to must have ansible chef puppet etc
all right let's move on to solutions
architectural
so this is also very popular role
responsibility of this role
is creating design based on organization
priority as in
uh is the organization trying to do lift
and shift
or lift to modernize shift or holy
modernization and then shift etc
you also have to do educate and advocate
so you have to go into strategic meeting
influence and educate people on the
design
you have to run workshop and demos this
role superpower is also
very versatile you can branch out to
other roles so
my current role is this one even though
i started with the devops architect
engineer
my current job deals with being a
solutions architect
so must have for this role is
you have to know compute network and
storage
services the cloud specific so for
example for aws
for compute you should know the
differences and different use cases when
to use what
between ec2 container like eks elastic
kubernetes service
lambda ecs etc network you have to know
how to like how vpcs work public
private etc and storage is super
important
so if you want to become a devops
architect devops engineer
you do not need to know anything about
really
network and storage that much but as a
solutions architect you need to know
different database options
what is the difference between rds
dynamodb
when to use what etc
next you need to study and be
comfortable
doing whiteboards on reference designs
and parameters
by parameter i mean think of five pillar
of architecture for aws um
like if some application wants to have
security
as the number one priority so how do you
change the design
if some application wants to have
performance as their highest priority
how do you change the design what kind
of parameter would you consider
etc so look up reference design uh for
specific stuff
do not need to study all the reference
design so you can pick like
10 maybe like maybe a streaming solution
a back-end api database etc
next must-have and a lot of people
actually ignore this
is presentation remember
solutions architect won't have anyone
reporting to them right
but you have to influence the whole
organization or a big team
their higher management so you have to
have presentation skills
to explain something in a simple terms
and you should be able to change your
level like if you are talking to a
director or executive director
you have to present in such a way that
you cannot go too
deep like they don't care technically
how much you know
you have to explain them the business
value and the high level design
and when you talk with the developers
think of like 20 30 developers you are
talking with
you have to change your level and
present it in such a way
that they get influenced and buy into
your design
so these are three musk tabs for
solutions architect
next highly recommended is the devops
component you should know a little bit
of code formation
and the pipelines for some of the
reference design but you do not need to
know
super deep in cloud formation like
you should have a working knowledge and
you should know how to look up the
cloud formation reference and uh
deploy something like if someone gives
you a design or you come up with a
design and you're trying to do a demo or
poc
you should be able to go pick up
confirmation commands and stitch
together the template
next highly recommended is you should
know at least one of these languages for
demo and proof of concept
python not js or go and last one highly
recommended is cloud certification
and the low return is chasing
shiny stuff so i have seen this a lot
actually
i'll give couple examples for example
there is a lot of buzz about being an
aiml
architect because i guess it's like
prestigious
but you have to do the groundwork for
that
and you yourself know whether you are
fit for it or no
so being a aiml solutions architect
requires
diving deep into lot of mathematical
formulas there is no way around it
right you cannot just learn the ai based
services
that does stuff for you for example like
recognition
you have to know sage maker and you have
to know how to
write machine learning code how to
select algorithm
how to clean up the data all that stuff
so
if you are not inclined to do all that
learning then
no need to chase that however if you
have a math background you like it
not just the status like you actually
like it and you want to learn it
then go for it similarly don't spend
time on like
blockchain services and stuff so what
skill did i learn
so i learned cloud formation i learned
confirmation deep dive
hands-on all that stuff i did not learn
terraform uh
till later i did the git command super
important
and then i actually did jenkins
i learned cloud specific things after i
got into the job
i did not learn it to get the interview
i i learned jenkins did hands-on
got into the job then learned cloud
specific stuff
devops pipelines i started i only
learned vm
while going to the interview but again i
was a devops architect engineer
like four and a half years back so now
you probably need to know
microservices as well uh going into
the role i knew virtual machines and
serverless so serverless was just
up and coming uh so i learned that i
learned container
way after the thing i really liked about
being a devops architect is
you give tangible output
like you are creating confirmation
templates
uh you are creating pipelines so it is
not just going and influencing people
you actually have
output and that actually uh felt made me
feel very productive
and actually learnt a lot had a lot of
fun in this role and then
before i switched to solutions architect
i had to work a lot on my presentation
school generally
i was a developer so uh generally
developers are a little weak on
presentation so i
i practiced a lot and i'm from india and
i have this funny accent
a lot of you guys and girls think it's
fake it's not it's stuck in between
india
and america and i'm actually married to
an american
so my accent is stuck in between
nothing i can do about it uh but thank
you for watching regardless of that i
know a lot of you guys and girls
uh think it's like a fake or something
anyway and then i learned i learned all
this compute storage and network
and then i learned reference design but
specific to the
company like i learned how to do a
regular three-tier architecture
api driven reference designs and then
i actually learned python before i
became a devops architect
i was doing a little bit of machine
learning that's when i knew that i could
not be
a good machine learning architect i have
to put considerable effort and i had a
lot
more to learn on other areas
uh so yeah so that's how i learned
python
okay so moving on to sysadmin security
governance engineer and architect so
this role entails you have to evaluate
processes
you have to evaluate new services the
pipelines whether the pipeline is
secure compliant application
configurations whether
something is kept open to be accessed by
the whole world infrastructure whether
infrastructure is secure
and you also have to automate some
processes such as compliance enforcement
like what if something goes wrong how do
you shut a service down
how do you alert how do you remediate
etc
superpower is you are the big daddy
uh like it is super critical and then
with the cloud jobs coming in there are
a lot of requirement for this role
a lot of good future as well so
if you are someone who likes security
you should look into this role
so must have for this is you need to
know
linux bash commands and scripting like
you need to know how to
bring up a server how to run different
commands in them
how to disable certain commands so that
users cannot
run those how to create different user
groups in linux etc
you should also know infrastructure as
code
because the input to you would be
the devops pipeline that the devops
architect or the
application team created and you need to
know whether
that pipeline is secure or not so you
have to have some basic knowledge
because you have to create
the compliance process that will go and
check
their template whether some security
group is
open or too permissive
etc next thing you need to know
is security and governance services and
this is cloud specific
so for aws for example you need to know
im
kms and some other services relevant to
security
such as messi guide duty etc
and for governance you should know
control tower
organization service catalog moving on
to highly recommended
so as a security or governance engineer
architect
you need to automate stuff as well
remember the scripting thing
so generally how companies run it today
is
uh they will write a lambda function uh
in python and instead of the bash script
running in linux
they will uh schedule this lambda
because it's way more cost effective and
easier to do
than the linux bash commands however
you still need to know linux based
commands and scripting but if you
know a little bit of python and lambda
you will be super valuable
next is security checklist so when you
are learning this security
and governance services like
the thing you are trying to learn is
what to look for to know
whether a particular application is
secure or not secure right like you are
not just
learning im and kms and
guard duty in vacuum you are learning
from an application standpoint like
if a specific security group or im role
is too permissive how to look for that
so you should have a security checklist
for applications
that's running on vm or container or
serverless
and so that you know what things to look
for what questions to ask the
application team
lastly you should have some security
certification this could be cloud
specific
such as security specialty or you could
get a comp ti
or something so one area a lot of
folks a little weak is network security
like green zone red zone
uh all that stuff generally in
interviews
people focus a lot on application and
data security
and not too much on the networking part
so networking part could be complicated
if you are not coming from a network
background
so do not need to don't need to dive
deep into the network security
to get into the job last one is a
software developers
these are the superheroes like if you
think about it at the end of the day
they get the job done if your company
doesn't have this forks no project will
be done like
if you have no architect maybe the
design will be crappy
but if you don't have any software
developer nothing could
be done so one thing is i uh
i have heard this question that raj i am
a developer and i want to become an
architect
to get into the cloud listen
if you are a software developer coding
on-prem stuff
you do not need to become an architect
to get into cloud
because there is a lot of demand and
very very high salary for cloud software
developer
so this is what you need to do so cloud
compatible coding you already have so
you need to know a
programming language that is compatible
with cloud or like
most applications in the cloud run their
codes in for example
python java node.js go
etc so if you if you uh are in mainframe
and you only know kobold
so you have to teach yourself one of
these languages so you can pick you can
pick python not js
but you need to know one language where
that cloud application is
written in if you already know this you
already won the battle
only thing you need to learn is how to
run
and test code in cloud let's say for
example you need to know
how to spin up ac2 deploy your code in
it manually no need to know
devops pipeline to get the job and how
to run it how to
execute it similarly for container for
lambda
same thing highly recommended the devops
components like if you know
cloudformation pipeline related to your
application
super useful cloud certification but
this is
not a as much of a big factor for
software developer as they are for the
architects
low return is algorithm overload
you should just study the algorithms
that's relevant to the job you are going
for
so how do you know what algorithm or
what actually questions to prepare
for this is applicable to
all these roles so what
i did and i would highly recommend is
you in the beginning look up the job
requirements in linkedin
like look up a few of the companies in
your area that are hiring and what kind
of
requirements they have let's say for
devops architect or soft solutions
architect
then for that company go to glassdoor
and look up
sample questions and then study those
and then you will be well equipped
to get the job so this is what i
personally followed
and that helped me a lot that's the
video guys and girls
let me know if you have any question
that i didn't go over or any particular
question about your role
and if you want to help this channel
grow please uh
click that big fat like button and
subscribe and i'll see you guys and
girls in the next
video bye